okay welcome to the walkthrough video
for true hallucinations this is going to
be part one in which we descend onto the
Amazon River and find our way to latter
era so I've decided to narrate this
whole thing it's probably not the best
idea but I just don't know how much time
I should leave with every dialogue until
you guys read it so it's easier to just
read it myself but you know please
consider getting the game and just play
it yourself then you won't hear my
stupid voice for hours and the first
thanks for your support if you actually
got the game through what's wrong so if
you want to get the game as soon as you
become my partner and you get a download
me for Mac and PC thanks for your
support anyway enjoy the game let's go
the year is 1992 Terence Mckenna is
considered to be the Timothy Leary of
the 90s his book true hallucinations has
just been released the book is about his
adventures in the Amazon rainforest with
his younger brother bunnies and a few
other friends what happened in those few
weeks changed his life forever
Terrence is about to finish his workshop
about psychedelics human evolution and
the archaic revival he doesn't suspect
that something extraordinary is about to
happen
so in closing I hope we can get this
phenomenon out of the closet and into
the general theater of debates about the
fate of the global civilization so that
we can begin to make real positive
changes because the clock is ticking
folks this is not a test
we have to either create some
fantastically brilliant forward escape
out of the grinding jaws of history or
we will be history thank you mmm that
was fun but now I want to get back to
Hawaii and chill out for a while
what is that it looks like some kind of
portal the place looks familiar
what is going on I recognize this place
but this happened 20 years ago
there's Dennis and my old friends this
was just before we went to the Amazon in
1971 and it seems it is 1971 oh man I
always said I would freak out if
something like this happened on the
natch well I guess I'm gonna have to
experience this whole thing all over
again I better talk to the others and
get back into the groove okay so
actually I wanna show you guys really
nice extra that I put into the game late
in its development but let's first go to
the food so this is f there's his
girlfriend
ready for the jungle oh I should mention
solo told me he will probably come with
us I hope it's not gonna cause any
tension this is Vanessa what's up
remember our late afternoons in the
experimental college fun times
please do this for Dave oh oh sorry I
was just meditating that's good going
yeah we already figured out most of the
trip and if any problem should arise
we'll just go with the flow
how's that for a plan really I'm Dave
okay so let's get going already
let's do this Dennis hey bro it's so
good to finally get out of Colorado I'm
really excited about that Charlie you
don't see anything different about me
I don't know Terry you look like you're
ready for anything
we should probably plan the first leg of
our journey with the others and if you
notice this thing on the table it's
these are eating coins and it's I put I
put them in a lot of places usually it
inside and whenever you see them you can
use them as fortune-telling device and
just form a question in your mind and
then throw it so let's find out if you
want to know more about the teaching
just check this out
should we okay let's let's learn more
about the itching department before the
Freud each ring is one of the oldest
books of ancient China and contains 64
hexagrams and texts on how to understand
them in the case of divination exa an
hexagon means six which refers to the
six lines that form a hexagon each of
these lines can be solid or broken that
means there are 64 possible combinations
of lines into hexagrams in each ink each
x gram is its own particular meaning of
divination so do the lines of it they
represent the yin and yang the basic
polarities of Chinese cosmology and
philosophy to obtain advice from the
eating about transfer and situation one
can consult it is an oracle to decide
which hexagram is related to the
situation at hand a hexagram is obtained
by throwing coins extra grams or sets of
six lines that can be broken or unbroken
the broken lines are again the unbroken
lines the end something is he and when
it is female or dark
earthly passive and the
when it is male or light heavily active
traditional video gene is found sorted
by phone fifty arrow stocks but usually
a set of frequencies used the coins are
phone six times while a question is had
in mind it is also possible to just let
the each in comment on your current
state when no question is held okay so
let's try it out is this game going to
be not successful in but when people
enjoy it so my hexagram out of the 64
variations is for youthful folate
springwells up at the foot of the
mountain the image of you does the
superior man fosters his character by
thoroughness and all that he does the
youth himself must be conscious of his
lack of experience and must seek out the
teacher without this modesty and
disinterest there is no guarantee that
he has the necessary receptivity which
should express itself and respectful
acceptance of the teacher this is the
reason why the teacher must wait to be
sought out instead of offering himself
characters develop the thoroughness that
keeps nothing but like water gradually
and steadily fuels up or gaps and so
close alright well I can see into that a
lot of things yeah it is what it is so
let's go to Colombia the airplane landed
us a few miles from the Rio Putumayo a
river whose vast expanse is the border
between Colombia and two southern
neighbors Ecuador and Peru I tried to
explain to Dennis what happened to me
but I crossed into a time warping portal
and landed 20 years ago in my past but
he just looked at me with his eyes
trained mind and said you know not from
the future sorry what is important is to
understand the true boundaries of
reality not the probable boundaries of
possible future events
[Music]
life is far stranger than most people
suppose out here on the river I feel my
older self melting away like a dream
it's amazing to feel 23 years old again
the image of me becoming a mushroom
growing permit and later a public person
advocating psychedelics is fading the
maid as Dennis and the gang grave on the
back
[Music]
I deliberately do not say much about any
of us they were misled you gated perhaps
without educated certainly then is
Vanessa F Dave and me but there was one
more person there solo dark he was a
boyfriend before I got together with her
but right now this is not important we
were refugees from a society that we
thought was poisoned by its own self
hatred and inner contradictions we had
no idea what to expect from the Amazon
but we have collected as much
ethnobotanical information as was
available this data told us where the
various hallucinogens were to be sought
but not what to expect when we found
them okay so this is this is not the way
where you can go for my do the story but
I just want to show you everything so
let's go here this is just a fun little
place with one lonely butterfly and if
you click on its instance home by the
word obsession butterflies which reminds
me I need to find my butterfly net you
know that huge white one I'm sure will
stumble into it at one point
spoiler alert okay this reminder
and here is a little house Oh nobody's
home
yes you can
if you're playing this game you know
just feel free to explore everything but
I just realized that you probably want
to move forward with your story and
there's another place back there but
let's just people you know what I am I'm
not going to show you guys everything
because I feel a little bit lazy about
it I made a small space where I could
sit cross-legged and draw the joint out
of the Extra Ordinary kilo of Santa
Marta by the flow of the river was like
the rich smoke I inhaled the flow of
smoke the flow of water and often
overflows so the beloved Greek
Heraclitus was called The Crying
philosopher as if she spoke in
desperation but why crying I love what
he says it does not make me cry
rather than interpret pamphlet area of
nothing less I had always considered
with the Western expression of the idea
of now and here we were going with the
put miles flow so whenever you see
dialog it means that you're going in the
right direction so as you can see it
this is probably not by the story
unfolds but let's just check it out
there's a mushroom there should be click
on there wonderful
it's a nicely regarded someone did you
check out what mushroom hmm I don't
think I should eat that let's look for
one that turns blue when you lose it
smart
got to be careful okay let's go
the right direction
[Music]
sometimes there are long opinionated
conversations with everyone animated and
taking part sometimes of silence falls
among us that lasts for several hours
watching the riverbank slide by
[Music]
today is the day of the full moon and
tomorrow we will arrive at El Encanto
there if present plans hold will meet
dr. Kuzma the tensions that divide us
have also surfaced when I sent so low we
have very little in common seem form
friends is this because I missed one a
son is not going to burn at all then it
is very quiet
Davis worrying about the food supply
he's a chronic worrier and naive he
seems to have thought that one just
takes off munchies and doors to an
Indian brother and says that one wants
to learn the secrets of the forest and
they say come my son come with us and
you will learn the secrets of the forest
now that he is actually confronted with
the Amazon jungle he seems a bit taken
aback
[Music]
solos animals are falling off the boat
into the river once an hour the captain
of the boat hates us because we have to
stop to drag these soaking monkeys out
of the drink shortly after dawn our
wrestle at the broad course of the pizza
mile and turned into the Rio para far
enough for the last few miles of the
journey to San Rafael
[Music]
so actually you can't go forward before
so you must get to the mission center
first and talk with but really good so
that means that we have a task and found
[Music]
this is actually our boat captain as
your captain I must say you were awful
passengers I'm glad you're now in the
hands of Padre Miguel we will take you
to the Train to Loretta thanks Lou okay
so we're looking for Padre Miguel hello
there welcome to Mission San Rafael I'm
Pedro Miguel what brings you to these
parts we want to get to la carrera
blanche Ferrara I can take you there by
boat tomorrow or at least the inland
trail to San Jose de el encanto we are
looking for dr. Alfredo Guzman yes dr.
Guzman is now mr. he passed through on
his way to return to his language
studies only three weeks before you may
be assured of finding him however before
I can take you there I need a favor and
that's one of my books on the shed
nearby please bring it back here then we
can go they'll also find your
possessions from the boat there and so
the butterfly that you've been looking
for
just remember to be bring back my tooth
as well
[Music]
so there's the share and there's
butterfly effects we can catch
butterflies but actually there are small
butterflies on large butterflies in the
game and you can only catch the odd ones
and here's a bookcase and yep 100 years
absolutely like that probably I Garcia
Marquez mm good choice Padre
well we got the book we've got the
butterfly now let's get back to Padre
Miguel
we have my book
yep excellent thank you let's get going
I take you to the trail go back to the
boat so we can go forward into the a
base
[Music]
I believe
[Music]
we were tearing over the surface of the
brown river the moving center moving
center of a festering wave of tremendous
mechanical noise the priest looked
considerably more humanity and the
beasts here with his brown casts are
bathing furiously in the wind that is
long beard trembling in the spray and
sunlight we anticipated the need for
porters to have carry our equipment but
the amiga said that we could get some
happiness and contour but now was the
time of hunting and man would be
reluctant to leave the hunt
[Music]
the engine cut off at what seemed the
last instant and then the shattering
silence we sleep like near ground on the
sandbar it was half a mile to the
village Padre Miguel explained as we
moved our supplies into a jumbo to keep
on the sand
[Music]
nice little found start to this guy no
way please
but there are free the booze - yes
doctor
our apologies for disturbing your
solitude and the local social
environment here but we are anxious to
push on to larger area and we hope that
we will help us arrange banners to go
with us but we are here with the special
purpose I refer to the viola Allison
agency reported to authorities so you're
looking for being ridiculous my friend
they're not going to get it
these people don't even speak Spanish
they speak only with total there were
40,000 of them killed were 50 years ago
they have no reason to like you and the
drug is super secret what are you doing
here I urge you to leave the jungle away
that is still possible we are not
turning back dr. Guzman very well my
naive friend I'll arrange barriers and
you can take the trail to Natural Area
but be there danger lurks everywhere
never swim alone is everywhere huge firm
smooth beneath its surface the rivers
abound with them snakes are everywhere
be aware of this as you make your way to
natural the forest is unforgiving the
fairway
you know what actually I think I'm gonna
stop here and I hope you guys enjoy this
I just want to break it down to chapters
and this is audience first chapter and
let's continue from here and please
again consider getting the game yourself
I think it's much more enjoyable that
wait and listening to my stupid voice so
but thanks for watching and see you in
the next chapter bye guys
[Music]